and i do this on all of these when i
and i initiate
and in aikido you you always say
who's the attacker not me
and yet if i initiate
it makes me this hacker
i need to
uh
an american teacher kayla vader who i
was really impressed with she used to
say she was a young girl when i met her
you say tony shout into the valley and
listen to the echo and it was uh that's
what gave me the idea if i could do that
and keep on here
the strongest person wins
it's called an attorney if i if i do
this touch and then take off
his brain for a split second doesn't
register that i'm attacking him
so it's it's uh it's an attempt like a
bluff to make him go what and in that
what moment
you tap them down
without that
your up gets this straight and you get
about here and then it starts getting
difficult
just to add that like splash
they go down
now
this is the tricky bit i step in
if i set them too far you could grab
that leg
so i have to step in here now this i've
got to take this this hand off so it's
it's a tricky moment so what i do is i
replace it
with this one
like that
i just go a little bit forward i don't
leave it there and just go like that
unless you can come up
so i replace it and i
do a quarter step forward that means he
has to then get his balance while it
gives me a moment to get his hand laid
i now follow the line
up my key
as i stand up and i turn my torso
towards you that puts that applies the
technique if i don't turn towards him
you stand up here
and he's okay he's going
you've not got me so i
turn my torso towards him like that i
pretend that this
this hand on the top part of my leg and
i just press it here
too much information isn't it
but i love it
because it is
technical
so most people in the harvey to do this
do this and get this pain
most men will do that so that's why
people often pack up my keto because
they're going i can't take that too much
bullying for me
splash
down
when you make the splashes before you be
more advanced when you make a splash
you've got to turn your hand like that
right splash you turn the end
up you start to turn from the hips
most of you should know it but
you know it's a little bit like going to
chinese not chinese it's like going to
america and you just all you want is a
caesar salad
i have a caesar salad please
when we used to go to california
and then the waitress would tell you the
dressings
and it would go on and on and on and in
the end
everybody look at each other and say
don't you dare ask me
because you know
i can't believe how many dressings they
do over there
so it's a little bit like that this
technique that's how you go it's got so
many variations
and the better you get the smoother it
becomes okay